tivité locale merci monsieur guy
geoffroy
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
notre assemblée a débuté hier soir
l'examen de vos deux projets de loi
organique et ordinaire portant
l'appellation bien qu'on peut au regard
de la réalité des textes de justice du
21e siècle
passe encore la méthode devenu habituel
et ordinaire de votre gouvernement qui
est la procédure accélérée qui ne permet
qu'une seule lecture dans chacune des
assemblées
peu importe la pratique spécifique à ce
texte qui consiste à ce que le
gouvernement amène massivement par voie
d'amendement des dispositions nouvelles
94 à nos demandes mans dans le cadre de
la première lecture par la commission et
14 amendements malgré l'engagement du
ministre de ne pas en faire plus lors de
la commission dite de l'article 88
tout ceci ne serait rien ne serait que
l'illustration de l'évanescence de votre
gouvernance actuelle s'il n'y avait pas
dans le texte du fait de votre accord à
des amendements proposés par ce qui
reste de votre majorité une disposition
parmi d'autres qui trouble qui troublent
et sur laquelle monsieur le premier
ministre il semble nécessaire que vous
apportiez de véritable explication je
veux parler de la disposition consistant
à supprimer les tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs cette disposition
vous avez pris la décision de
l'apprendre au seul motif que seulement
1% des délits en cause seraient traitées
par les tribunaux correctionnels pour
mineurs c'est un aveu d'idéologie qui
domine tout monsieur le premier ministre
quand s'agissant de la justice des
mineurs qui demande responsabilité allez
vous quitter le terrain de l'idéologie
qui déconstruit pour rester sur celui de
la responsabilité qui doit être la seule
marque d'un gouvernement responsable
la parole est à nos yeux jean jacques
urvoas garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice monsieur le député guy geoffroy
nous poursuivons ainsi la conversation
que nous avons entamé dans l'hémicycle
hier soir à l'occasion de la discussion
est donc
souffrez que je réponde à la place du
premier ministre que vous avez
interpellé
je trouve votre question en réalité
assez évidente
je lui ai dit hier le mérite que vous
avez vous eric ciotti d'autres collègues
c'est que vous nous faites à chaque fois
les mêmes arguments sans amener un
élément nouveau c'est une forme de
best-of des républicains et donc c'est
un avantage c'est qu'il ya plus de
surprises et de ce point de vue je
crains de vous décevoir puisque je n'ai
pas d'autres arguments à vous dire que
ceux des faits vous savez très bien
monsieur le député qui lie à une censure
du conseil constitutionnel le 3 août
2011 sur les tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs qui ont vidé cette mesure
de sa principale intérêts prétendu c'est
à dire la rapidité à sanctionner s'il y
a aujourd'hui 0,8 pour cent des
condamnations de délinquance sur mineur
fait par les tribunaux correctionnels
combine heures c'est parce que la mesure
a été vidé de son sens par le conseil
constitutionnel
en sus en sus vous y avez mis une
organisation extrêmement complexe
puisqu'il faut plusieurs magistrats dans
un tribunal or la plupart d'entre eux ne
sont pas spécialisés en matière de
juridiction des enfants et donc cela
désorganise les juridictions vous
connaissez bien le monde de la justice
monsieur le député je vous propose que
nous allions ensemble dans n'importe
quelle juridiction de france et nous
verrons ce que disent les magistrats sur
ce tribunal correctionnel pour mineurs
je n'ai aucune inquiétude absolument
venez quand vous voulez monsieur le
député et donc vous allez voir surtout
que la suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs ne va rien
changer au contraire la sévérité sera
plus forte puisque les tribunaux pour
enfants en ferme plus puisque c'est ça
votre mesure de référence
elle enferme plus que donc ce sera vous
serez rassurés et nous aussi parce que
nous allons donner la priorité à
l'éducatif pour combattre la délinquance
des mineurs
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux